mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour du beau temps partout en france
à quelques nuages près des voitures
encore des voitures sur les routes de
france décor encore tout blanc pour
l'instant sur les plages et dans les
prêts et vous vous qui nous écoutent et
qui n'aide pas encore partis en vacances
mais qui profite et quand même je
l'espère de ce week end le plus long de
l'ère l'actualité aujourd'hui et bien
sûr en relation étroite avec cette
période de vacances et les accidents
d'été à la mer à la montagne sur les
routes sont déjà trop nombreux
nous en reparlerons en france ce matin
la principale information concerne le
procès dit de puyricard jugé à aix en
provence et qui s'est terminée hier soir
arlette boulbès a été condamné à 12 ans
de réclusion criminelle
sauveur pas de vanille et géo costeraste
à 8 ans de la même veine les jurés et
les juges ont donc lundi mme conviction
que les trois complices ont bel est bien
supprimée lucia izoard la gouvernante
qui se faisait rappelez-vous à l'achat
de la propriété du vicomte de régis à
public
en tout cas la fin de ce procès a été
marqué par des incidents divers et nous
allons maintenant retrouver georges
valter qui était cette nuit même
quelques minutes après le verdict qui
était devant le palais de justice d'aix
en provence
il est une heure du matin dans ce petit
café de la place de verdun avec ce en
provence à quelques pas du palais de
justice
il ya quelques minutes seulement que
vient de se disperser une foule excitée
et chauffée par la température et par
les événements en effet on vient
d'arrêter joseph boulbès leurs airs
d'arlette boulbès qui vient d'être
condamné il a été arrêté pour outrage à
agent pour outrage
il a été arrêté pour outrage à magistrat
et sera déféré demain matin à 10h en
audience de flagrant délit
mais revenons en arrière les jurés se
sont enfermés pour délibérer pendant
deux heures 25 avant qu'ils délibèrent
on avait fait venir extrait de sa plage
de sanary à témoin que
les jurés avaient considéré un moment
donné comme important puisqu'il
représentait de la libye de gaston
costeraste jo l'aixois
c'est pierre pagans qui vient déclarer
qu'il se trouvait avec joe l'exploit à
marseille alors du drame de puyricard
mais il n'est pas très convaincant si la
demande exactement ce qui s'était passé
je suis exactement raconter ce qui s'est
passé les quatre acheteurs assez bien
les comme moi le 28 juillet c'est tout
ce que j'ai à dire sur les mannequins
mais l'avocat général n'a pas posé une
question or l'avocat général
bien sûr si son travail il pose des
questions mais
moyenne spéciale
le jury se retire pour délibérer dans la
salle des pas perdus
on se presse beaucoup de gens en habit
venue du festival d'aix sans doute pour
assister en cette fin de nuit à un autre
spectacle
après 2h25 de délibérations la cour va
rendre son arrêt arlette boulbès 12 ans
de réclusion criminelle
sauveur padovani huit ans
gaston costeraste dijeaux l'aixois huit
ans aussi s'il vous plaît
c'est alors qu'éclate les incidents
autour de la famille darling baisse
confort josette rappelle magistrature ou
de gras pour avoir traité le procureur
d'assassins il sera arrêté inculpé d'
outrage à magistrat il risque un mois de
feindre dans ce procès en tout cas le
plus difficile semble-t-il pour les
jurés pour les juges a été de faire la
part des preuves des débuts de preuves
des semis preuves et des présomptions en
tout cas georges walter nous en parlera
ce soir à 20 ans je vous disais tout à
l'heure que l'actualité de ce dimanche
concernaient pour beaucoup ce mois
d'août avant la lettre
enfin ces vacances que viennent de
prendre des millions de français en
profitant de ce conte du 14 juillet on a
compté près de paris sur la route des
vacances 15% de plus d'automobilistes
que l'année dernière à pareille époque
mais malheureusement déjà il nous faut
ouvrir cette navrante de rubriques des
drames de l'été et dont l'exemple
rappelez-vous l'exemple le plus frappant
a été celui de la disparition de
monsieur félix gaillard et de ses amis
et à ce propos dès maintenant certain
qu'un incendie suivi d'une explosion
soit la cause du naufrage et en
examinant les corps des victimes ramené
hier soir par la vedette des douanes à
lézardrieux
on a pu reconstituer en partie le drame
on sait sans doute que le feu a pris à
bord de la marie grillons d'ailleurs les
restes du board et que nous voyons pour
bien qu'il ya eu incendie et explosion
les femmes donc ont dû évacuer le bord
les deux hommes ont sans doute lutter
dans un premier temps contre l' incendie
avant qu'une autre explosion de les
précipite dans l'eau blessés et brûlés
aujourd'hui le corps de monsieur félix
gaillard doit être transporté à
barbezieux dans la charpente et dès hier
le président de la république monsieur
georges pompidou adressait une lettre à
madame félix gaillard profondément
attaché aux valeurs du libéralisme le
président félix gaillard a fait preuve
tout au long de sa carrière politique
d'une élévation d'esprit et de caractère
digne d'un homme d'état et parmi les
multiples témoignages et hommages rendus
à l'ancien président nous pouvons
retenir également la déclaration de
monsieur edgar faure j'ai bien connu
philippe gas year il était venu à la
politique par la résistance vous avez
joué un rôle de mérite et nous avons été
surpris hier d'une équipe de jeunes
députés en fait ils étaient plus jeunes
que moi d'ailleurs
nous sommes entrés tous à la chambre en
même temps en 1946 il y avait beau geste
maunoury félix gaillard moi même et puis
alors des gens comme jean masson emile
hugues qui avait déjà occupé des mandats
j'ai beaucoup apprécié félix gaillard
c'était un homme très solide
il réussissait dans tout il avait été
champion de natation en même temps que
premier à l'inspection des finances
quand j'ai fait mon temps me
gouvernement en 1952 je lui ai demandé
d'être côté de moi comme secrétaire
d'état à la présidence du conseil
il descendait toujours par un petit
escalier kona ils entrés par une petite
porte dans notre épicerie venait me
raconter des affaires dont il s'occupait
ensuite il a été ministre des finances
dans un autre gouvernement et je crois
qu'il a rendu beaucoup de services comme
ministre des finances notamment à la
classe agricole au point de vue de
l'agriculture il avait fait beaucoup de
choses
récemment encore d'abord je déjeunais
avec lui dans l'intimité il ya quelques
mois nous avons eu une longue
conversation très confiante si je puis
dire très amicale et encore notre jour
presque c'était très très peu de temps
et de très peu de temps après mon
émission à la télévision j'ai rencontré
le couloir je fais compliment pour un
article qui levait publié dans le figaro
sur le dollar est immédiat je vois que
tu n'a tenu compte dans tes propos sur
les questions financières
vraiment je pense que c'est une grande
perte pour le pays pour la classe
politique et je tiens également à
adresser l'expression toute mon émotion
à sa femme et à sa famille je suis
vraiment outré peiné de cette nouvelle
malheureusement la mer ou la route ne
sont pas les seules causes de ces drames
de l'été en effet la montagne est aussi
responsable de bon nombre d'accidents et
c'est est né sachez que depuis le mois
de mai on compte déjà 21 morts et 33
blessés dans les alpes françaises
le club alpin s'inquiète de la situation
et dans un communiqué le club demande
aux halpenny
de se méfier particulièrement des
plaques de neige des névés qui subsiste
encore de préférence sur les versants
nord et ce en raison de l'enneigement
exceptionnel que vous connaissez
enneigement donc de cet hiver ce matin
encore d'ailleurs trois jeunes
alpinistes ont dévissé dans le massif du
mont blanc
ils ont été transportés à l'hôpital de
chalon dans cette longue liste
d'accidents de toutes sortes que je
voudrais quand même pas trop prolonger
bien sûr des accidents de la route
mais il faudra attendre demain pour
savoir si les automobilistes ont eu plus
de chance ou ont été plus raisonnables
que l'année passée en tout cas pour ceux
qui roulent maintenant sur les routes
des vacances et plus particulièrement
pour ceux qui roulent vers la côte ouest
de l'espagne
une bonne nouvelle cette route à qui
manquait tant de pont en traversant le
pays basque s'améliore de jour en après
les doubles voies jeté sur la bidassoa
et entre les deux quartiers de bordeaux
hier monsieur jacques chaban delmas
inauguraient un troisième pont de grande
dimension à bayonne messieurs jacques
chaban delmas premier ministre procédé
hier à une série d'inaugurations la
première était celle d'un tronçon
d'autoroute de 10 km amorce de celle qui
reliera bientôt bordeaux un arbre cette
autoroute n'est ni la première ni la
dernière construite dans cette région
déjà saint-andré de cubzac et relié à
bordeaux par un tronçon qui
malheureusement s'achève justement à
saint-andré-de-cubzac par un pont
ralentissant considérablement la
circulation
monsieur chaban delmas a également
annoncé l'ouverture prochaine des
travaux de l'autoroute de la côte basque
parallèle à la route actuelle des landes
s'est ensuite l'inauguration du deuxième
pont franchissant l'adour d'une
importance capitale pour l'amélioration
du trafic pour l'entrée et la sortie de
la ville de bayonne
une inauguration celle d'un pont de 60
mètres de long passant sur la nationale
10 impossible à traverser à cet endroit
et reliant les deux villes organisent et
lormont et cenon sur la rive droite de
la garonne pour les automobilistes ce
sont de bonnes nouvelles et
principalement au moment des départs en
vacances
et bien maintenant pour les affaires
internationales
disons que c'est un calme relatif que
nous apporte ce dimanche pour le proche
orient à moscou à londres et à
washington les conversations se
poursuivent et l'ont examiné avec
attention les dernières propositions
soviétique
on est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
attentifs à ce qui risque de se passer
en irlande du nord car vous savez c'est
demain que doit avoir lieu ce fameux
défilé des protestants et ce contre
défilé des catholiques à travers les
rues de belfast
le gouvernement a interdit toute vente
de boissons alcoolisées dans tout le
pays
en tout cas la nuit a été calme en
espagne on apprenait ce matin la mort
d'un des plus anciens compagnons du
général franco le général mignaux ce
green day ce qui fut l'un des
personnages les plus importants du
régime franquiste
né en 1896 à madrid le général burundais
se distinguent pendant la guerre civile
dans le nord de l'espagne puis un peu
plus tard au cours de la seconde guerre
mondiale sur le front russe à la tête de
la fameuse division azul conseiller du
royaume chef du hot état-major ministre
des armées vice président du conseil
il doit abandonner cependant la vie
politique active en 1967
hospitalisé depuis un an le général
grande s était ainsi hier à madrid à
l'âge de 74 ans le domaine des sports
maintenant
eddy merckx va bien tout embarrassé
qu'il soit par sa garde-robe de
champions qui va du maillot jaune au
maillot vert
en tout cas les coureurs ce centre
seront ce soir pardon à toulouse
et aux dernières nouvelles tout allait
bien dans le club
la natation la natation et la discipline
de prédilection est en vedette pour ce
week-end au stade georges vallerey se
déroulent les grand prix de paris de
natation claude mandonnaud a réalisé une
minute deux secondes sur 100 mètres et
michel rousseau a remporté le 200 m
pendant ce temps en californie une jeune
américaine de 17 ans karen mok
s'approprier le record du monde du 200 m
papillon en 2 minutes 20 secondes 7/10
autre performance non sportives mais ce
fut quand même un beau match voici tout
sourire la gagnante du concours miss
univers 1970 smith porto rico la
bataille s'est joué sur quelques
centimètres là aussi et nous ferions
bien avec ces demoiselles avec elle et
ses dauphines de miss univers nous
ferions bien quelques pas dans les
étangs je ne sais pas si nous avons
maintenant le temps oui je pense
d'ailleurs nous allons prendre quelques
minutes de vacances supplémentaires en
terre occitane disons en effet à
saint-pierre ge de gris science se
déroule chaque année des fêtes
folkloriques de grand intérêt je pense
que nous pouvons les passer
faux
il y a un peu plus de 2000 ans un romain
nommé gruss use créer ici un peur au
cours des âges
accroché à son piton rocheux nourrissant
se développe
la légende voudrait que barberousse le
fameux pirates barbaresques en effet un
de ces refuges latour éventré qui
dominent des toits mort dorée porte son
nom ici dit on dans la région les choses
ne sont pas exactement ce qu'elles sont
ailleurs
qu'en pense monsieur le maire vous savez
c'est difficile à dire c'est celle à
tour ce sont les vieilles maisons sur
les vieux dans les cagnards au soleil ce
sont les jeunes et c'est tout ce qui
nous intéresse aussi ici c'est tout ce
que vous découvrez avec quand vous êtes
à griesheim un peu le coeur rue ça l'est
parce que c'est les prospectus c'est un
les 800 ça se vit quand on parle de
gruissan dans la région de narbonne on
dit outre chose de gruissan par un peu
particulier un pirate
vous savez il faudra découvrir la
définition du mot pirates arriver ça
lingots d'or comme vous lira bensaou
battre sans eux mais je crois qu'il faut
quand il faut donner au mot pirate le le
sens de deux pionniers si vous voulez
déjà tourné vers les choses de la mer il
y à une centaine d'années encore il y
avait une soixantaine de bâtiments à
gruissan ces bâtiments où on était assez
important si j'arrivais de 300 tonneaux
environ
les plus gros et les plus petites rentes
tonneaux et il s'est consacré et à la
pêche bien sûr mais aussi à tout le
trafic maritime et une pêche un petit
peu particulier ici est pêché en général
ça pêche en mer vous pêchez à la foulée
robert et et en gt et aux étangs
qu'est-ce qui se prendre c est en mai 1
c est un frein du loup de la daurade
petites et grosses du mulet des
anguilles en de l'apli de la chambre et
surtout d
beaucoup d'engouement ce thème éthique
et très rude très dur et pata pon
bien sûr ça n'ira pas s'arrêter-là pas
du jour au lendemain en vain j'en à
venir peut-être gagner bien la pêche
évolution la même peut-être ma région a
disparu mais dans l'immédiat
st-pierre fête des pêcheurs demeure au
nom du premier ministre
nous vous faisons chevalier dans l'ordre
du mérite maritime et je vous embrasse
mais
c'est dans l'église que la sole it
atteint son maximum
monsieur le curé nous explique ce qui y
est il ya la forme des pêcheurs
cette offrande des pêcheurs a lieu au
son de bain scottish et c'est sur un
parent de danse en quelque sorte qu'ils
viennent d'offrir le travail de de leur
année
et bien même s'il ne s'agit pas d'un
jour de fête
arrêtez-vous peut-être à saint-pierre de
russian si vous êtes dans la région
voilà notre émission est maintenant
terminée bonnes vacances pour ceux
d'ailleurs qui vont partir ou qui sont
partis quant à ceux qui restent ceux qui
sont dans les villes dans le capital et
bien par exemple ce matin à 7h paris
était bien joli et très calme bonne
journée à tous
m